hello everyone and welcome to the
genetics and genomics virtual event my
name is Jonathan Schafer and I'm a
associate director in research and
development at hydrogen and I will be
presenting on next-generation
transcriptome in micro note sequencing
intelligent approaches to insightful
outcomes please feel free to submit
questions during my presentation and I
will follow up with you via email
if our standard legal disclaimer the
kaijin products shown here are intended
for molecular biology applications and
these products are not intended for the
diagnosis prevention or treatment of a
disease so for today's agenda we want to
begin with an RNA focused NGS overview
and then we'll go into the meat of the
presentation we'll begin with RNA
extraction then move into library
preparation follow the sequencing then
discuss analysis and ultimately conclude
with an overview of our genomic services
and a summary and then we'll fill any
questions
so let's begin with an RNA focused NGS
overview
RNA focused next-generation sequencing
enables a thorough investigation of both
coding and non-coding RNAs RNA NGS has a
variety of specific applications for
gene expression pathway analysis
biomarker discovery allele-specific
expression fusion gene analysis tumor
heterogeneity assessment immune
repertoire as well as single cell
sequencing and your specific analytes
can vary across RNA NGS from your small
guys your micro RNAs that are
approximately 21 to 22 nucleotides your
PI RNAs that are about 30 base pairs all
the way up to your mRNAs and in between
you have your tRNAs your pre micro RNA
chor snow RNAs your long non-coding RNAs
so if you look collectively at the RNA
universe there's quite a bit of analytes
that have a variety of unique features
if you look at three distinct RNAs mRNAs
long non-coding RNAs and micro rna's and
small RNAs each one have unique
individual properties mRNAs are
obviously coding they range in length
from two hundred to a hundred thousand
nucleotides they have a five prime cap
and they have a poly a tail so poly tail
here is one of the key features of your
mRNAs there's about 21,000 human genes
and the broad range of expression goes
from very low to very high long
non-coding rnas are both non-coding and
they have regulatory functions their
size is about the same as mrna s but one
difference is that they may or may not
have poly a tails and my experience is
that you cannot rely on having poly a
tails when assessing long non-coding
RNAs so it's basically best to assume
that they do not have them now moving on
to micro rnas and small rnas this is an
own universe that these small RNAs have
their non-coding and they do possess
regulatory functions like their long
non-coding counterparts but these guys
are only 19 to 25 nucleotides
they have no poly a and there's only
about 2600 or so human micro rna's and
they vary an expression from very low to
very high and our first tip comes that
the unique properties of rnas
demands specialized library prep
solutions
so now let's take a look at what I term
the pyramid of NGS success your NGS
quality depends on quite a number of
things at the base of the pyramid is
your sample source and then one level up
is your actual sample working our way up
further is that you need to have high
quality extracted RNA you need to
include the correct library preparation
kit ultimately your sequencing needs to
be both tailored for your RNA analytes
of interest and you need to also
allocate correct read budget for your
RNAs and ultimately at the top of the
pyramid is both primary secondary and
tertiary analysis and at the pinnacle
you reach your ultimate NGS success
so when you're working with a variety of
RNA sequencing the samples that you will
be typically using our fresh frozen
cells and tissues FFPE tissues they're
in plasma bio fluids as well as whole
blood and one of my tips is that you
want to choose your sample prep kits
that provide you with the flexibility to
analyze all RNAs and we'll touch on this
as we move into the next section but
what I mean is that if you have interest
in small RNAs you want to choose an
isolation kit that isolates both your
small RNAs
so your micro RNAs as well as your long
RNA your long non-coding RNAs and your
mRNAs you don't want to choose a kit
that just isolate your mRNAs and long
non-coding RNA
to the second point in our agenda let's
discuss RNA extraction
so here Teijin we've built our
reputation over decades now on providing
the gold standard for sample preparation
and this includes RNA and basically we
have a total RNA solution for every
sample type
for fresh frozen cells and tissues we
have our micro and easy family of kits
and basically these enable you to
isolate both your small RNA and your
long RNA all in one element it's
basically your true total RNA you're
Arnie Zeek it's typically isolate your
long rnase only and you're all prep can
give you your DNA RNA and micro RNA all
in separate Elliots 4fp tissue we have
the micro RNA z kits as well as again
the all prep kits German plasma we have
the micro an easy serum plasma advanced
kit which is a Keisel chloroform free
kit we also have our traditional micro
and easy serum plasma kit that is kaizo
chloroform based and we have the Chi amp
circulating cell free DNA RNA kit for
exosome enrichment and isolation from
serum and plasma we have the xor and
easy serum plasma midi and maxie kit if
you want to know the difference it
basically boils down to these kits
accepting different amounts of input
sample furthermore we have the packs
gene blood my grenade kicked in the
packaging tissue micro RNA kit that are
compatible with the pax gene tubes as a
tip here heparin is very potent reverse
transcription inhibitor and this comes
into play when working with plasma
samples and basically if you have a
heparin collection tube that these
massively inhibit your ability to do
reverse transcription and you don't
receive any library however we do have a
solution for this and this is something
that you can ask a question about but we
do have a customized protocol from
Teijin R&D that enables you to remove
heparin from your samples looking at the
micro SD serum plasma advanced solutions
in more detail we have the micro SD
serum plasma advanced kit as well as the
advanced high a cube HT kit and looking
in more detail for the on the left here
for the serum plasma advanced kit the
except serum and plasma start with 200
microliters of sample material going in
your RNA le width is 10 to 20
microliters which is more than adequate
to perform next-generation sequencing
library prep with and the spin column
format you can automate up to 12 in a
kayak cube connect now for the 96-well
plate you can again use up to 200
microliters your RNA eliwood
is a little bit higher but you can do 24
to 96 samples in batches of 8
two sample prep instrumentation on the
top left we have a kaya cube HT which
offers a sample size of a 96-well format
and the isolation kit that is compatible
is the rtz 96 tie a cube HT kit and the
top right is a new sample prep device
that we have out this is a kaya cube
connect and you can perform 12 samples
per run and it is able to automate over
80 tides and kits with over 3,000
protocols and this includes both DNA and
RNA as well as protein also in the new
tie a cube connect there is a UV light
for decontamination and on the bottom we
have a kaya expert this is used for
quantification and quality controlled
DNA and RNA and the sample input is one
point five to two thousand and four
microliter in this preloaded apps for
your isolation kit very nicely you can
quantify and qualify up to 16 samples in
two minutes
body control recommendations for RNA
samples now we look at concentration for
fresh and frozen cells and tissue as
well as FPE we use the standard
spectrophotometer and I say no QC for
serum and plasma so before you all get
upset that I'm saying well no QC how can
you have no QC we'll go through and then
I'll discuss the serum and plasma at the
end so for purity so your 260 to 280 and
260 230 ratios we again recommend a
standard spec but for serum and plasma
again OTC and for size distribution
analysis we recommend Akai Excel a
bioanalyzer tape station or fragment
analyzer and again though for serum and
plasma no QC so we don't recommend to c4
serum and plasma or concentration
assessments because a lot of the
concentration readings and quality
assessments are based off of the
presence of ribosomal RNA and in serum
and plasma there is not a high amount of
ribosomal RNA and as a result your
concentration readings look artificially
low with serum and plasma as well as
your purity looks quite bad and your
size distribution is basically
non-existent for serum and plasma just
because your ribosomal RNA isn't there
to interpret and instead how we deal
with serum and plasma typically is that
you add a fixed volume of your RNA tell
you it based off of the amount of sample
that went into your isolation kit
and on the right here we have the Chi
Excel advanced and this is again used
for size distribution analysis you can
work without the 96 samples per run and
it's basically 12 samples in three
minutes and an RNA integrity score or
risk score is provided
let's shift gears from talking about RNA
extraction to working with our library
prep so first off when you're working
with whole transcriptome NGS typically
in Richmond Road repletion is necessary
to maximize your reads from your rnase
of interest this is because in a given
cell greater than 80% of your RNA is
from ribosomal RNA and highly abundant
transcripts
consume a lot of reads and around this
enriched murder depletion is used to
obtain more reads from your rnase of
interest such as your mRNAs and your
long non-coding rnas so your enrichment
or depletion strategies are that you can
poly a select or any RNAs that contain
poly a tails and as I mentioned
previously in the webinar this is when
you're working exclusively with mRNAs
that long non-coding RNAs may or may not
have poly a's so there's no guarantee
that if you poly enrich that you'll
actually select for your long non-coding
rnas and at the bottom we have ribosomal
depletion so basically what the magnate
here is doing is it's removing your
ribosomal RNA and basically everything
else is left in your samples so this
includes your mRNAs and your long
non-coding RNA
and ultimately the strategy of selection
depends on the objective of your whole
transcriptome sequencing if you're only
interested in mRNAs I would poly a
select if you're interested in in in all
of your RNAs so your mRNAs and your long
non-coding RNAs I would ribosomal
deplete
so if you look at ribosomal depletion
methods traditionally there have been
hybrid capture or or RN ACH methods and
these are often pretreatment methods
that take more than two hours and 29
steps so we won't go through this in
exhaustive detail here but if you look
at a hybrid capture method you have 12
steps of bead washing five steps of
probe hybridization six step steps to
remove your ribosome RNA and fourteen
steps to purify your RNA so about let's
see there that is twenty twenty-five
thirty seven steps you've removed you
two ribosomal RNA then RNase H is a
little bit quicker on the steps but it
still takes just as long and about two
hours so collectively the hybrid capture
and RNase H methods that are quite
popular are pretreatment methodologies
that are time-consuming time-consuming
and arduous and you have a higher chance
for sample prep sample loss and again
here all you're doing is removing
ribosome RNA so tae Jin what we've
developed is a patent-pending technology
that is rapidly rapidly much better and
faster than any other method so if you
look at the other methods from supplier
I and NK you have 30 plus manual
protocol steps and about two hours and I
think fast select requires only one step
and twenty minutes and removes basically
all of your ribosomal RNA importantly
it's also compatible with virtually any
RNA library prep kit so what we've done
here kaijin is that again you're just
removing ribosomal RNA so why in the
world should it take you two hours and
thirty steps to do this we've changed
the way we're doing things and we've
reduced this down to one step and twenty
minutes
we go into the specifics of how kai
seeks a select works basically it you
combine it with your RNA sample in the
top bubble here you then perform
fragmentation if your library kits in
sample type require it then step three
you stepwise cool your sample from 75
degrees to 25 degrees over twenty
minutes this is basically where fast
select is working and then you complete
your remaining library preps what this
kit does is it removes cytoplasmic and
mitochondrial ribosome RNA and or globin
mRNA and it works with human Mouse Ratan
custom and it works by blocking cDNA
synthesis of unwanted RNAs so this is
added during your library prep and you
prevent ribosomal RNA from being
synthesized into cDNA importantly no
enrichments or cleanups are needed it's
compatible with all types of samples
from FFPE blood biofluids tissues and
cell lines it can work with one nanogram
to one microgram of RNA and we've tested
its compatibility with the kaya seek
stranded toad RNA library get true seek
it from Illumina any be next from any D
and the Kappa RNA Piper prep from Roche
looking at some performance data fast
select offers robust
performance in addition to speed so for
this experiment we took 100 nanogram
Alec lots of universal human reference
RNA we either did no treatment or poly a
selected the mRNA or performed ribosomal
depletion with rather zero from aluminum
or hi seeks a select so if you look at
the percentage of our RNA reads with no
treatment you see about 90% of your
reads for poly a enrichment you see
about one percent rather zero gold about
four to five percent because it's a
select about one percent importantly in
the to scatter plots then you have Kai
seek faff select on the x-axis and no
treatment on the y-axis for the center
graph and you can see that when you look
at the remaining genes between Kai
success elect and no treatment you have
basically the expression falls on a
straight line with an R square root of
0.9 for suggesting that that select is
not disturbing gene expression profiles
in addition on the right when you
compare fast selective ribose your gold
the gene expression again then falls on
a straight line so even though we are
using only one step in twenty minutes
we're not disturbing the gene expression
profile
one more slide when you look at tae
sik's a selective with FFPE samples fast
select likes to work with very degraded
samples which isn't always the case for
other ribosomal depletion technologies
so for example when you look at Chi C
fast select with FFPE samples basically
the colored diamonds represent
replicates and the same samples were
used for both guys d-class elected
rather Zira gold Isaac fat select the
remaining ribosomal RNA was all at about
1% while forever Z rolled the ribosomal
RNA remaining was 6 to 10% in addition
when you look at the gene expression
between 2 replicates the concordance was
in r-squared of 0.9 - for fast select or
normal FF e and on the bottom it was
0.96 or cancer FFP now this has been
comparison to four riders e revolt the R
squared was only point eight two and it
was 0.83 for cancer at the p in addition
one of the things to note is as ribose
Eero is a pretreatment technology these
samples required much more amplification
suggesting loss of sample material so
not only this fast select remove more
ribosome RNA your gene expression is
more stable and reproducible and you do
not lose a material like to do with Rui
bizarro
Pfaff select is then again compatible
with acai seek stranded total RNA
library kit as well as the true seat
stranded and he be next in the capital
RNA hyper prep ultimately fast select is
compatible with most are any library
prep kits and if you have any questions
about what kits that kaya seek is a
select is compatible with just send me a
question or an email and I can work with
you for a protocol
so now let's shift gears naturally into
talking about the Chi seek stranded RNA
sequencing kids so we have two one is
the stranded mRNA select kits so this is
where you select for mRNAs and then
perform library prep and the second kit
is just the stranded kit so this is
where you would combine the chi seek
fast select for ribosomal depletion with
the chi seek stranded total RNA library
kit on the bottom
so the Chi Sikh stranded library kits
perform a make a stranded library kit
without act in amaizing D or D ETP to
work through the workflow you start with
your RNA and then perform fragmentation
and fast select ribosomal inner glow'
button removal following this you work
your way down and perform first strand
synthesis second strand synthesis is
then second strand synthesis and repair
and a addition is performed and second
strand synthesis is performed with
phosphorylated random primers and what
this does is that when you perform your
adapter ligation you're only ligating to
the phosphorylated second strand and
this is depicted here next to adapter
ligation and you can see that you like
eight strands to only the five prime end
of the phosphorylated second strand and
then the three prime ends of the of the
other end and ultimately then when you
perform library amplification you're
only amplifying one strand namely the
second strand and this is how we derived
strand myth in the chi seek stranded
libraries
so when you bench mark Takai seek
stranded kid and supplier tea using the
CQC samples so these are universal human
reference RNA and human brain reference
RNA and to titrations of these the
stranded miss is basically identical
between the two kids so even though
we're deriving strand in this in a
different manner the stranded nough
still very high on the order of 98%
so now you look at a principle component
analysis of the reference samples the
samples segregate as suggested but you
have universal human reference RNA three
parts human reference RNA to one part
human brain RNA is closest to the you HR
r then you have one part you HRR to
three parts h BR r and ultimately h BR r
is up to the top right so as you can see
the more you h RR so the three two one
clusters closely the you h RR and the
more h BR are in the one part you h RR
two three parts hv r are clusters
closely with HB r r and on the right
then you have the clustering of both the
chi seek and supplier t that all of
these are together here on the same
chart and these kits demonstrate both
similar stranded nacelle as expression
profiles
so now let's shift gears from whole
transcriptome analysis and discuss
targeted RNA NGS so why should you
perform targeted RNA NGS basically the
user defines the targeted regions and
not all ranges in the transcriptome are
relevant so what this allows you to do
is focus only on what is relevant to you
second point is that it improves your
limit of detection or LOD and this is
because you're more read budget is
allocated to each sample this enables
you to have a deeper depth of coverage
and leads to an increased confidence in
calling low expression genes third point
is it can multiplex more samples
together because you're using again your
read budget more efficiently and smaller
targeted regions enable higher sample
sample multiplexing and the last point
is why should you perform high seek
targeted RNA NGS and this is because
both library amplification and
sequencing bias are removed and this is
accomplished using unique molecular
indices or um I
let's now look at um eyes but here we
have the principle of unique molecular
index so you have two genes here in 1
and G 2 and in the original sample you
have three copies of gene one and two
copies of gene two giving you a ratio of
three parts to two okay so now if you go
through a NGS library kit workflow
without um eyes and just interpret your
raw reads so we'll just look at the bars
on the left under raw reads you have
twelve reads of gene one and six threes
of gene two now this leads to a ratio of
two parts to one and what this suggests
though is a different sample complexity
compared to your original sample so
originally you are three to two and if
you just interpret your raw reads you're
two to one so now let's integrate um
eyes into the workflow so prior to
amplification each molecule is tagged
with its own unique molecular ID so each
copy of gene 1 and gene to receive its
own unique sequence so then when you
amplify and sequence and look now at the
small colored bars on under the raw
reads the reads are collapsed based off
of the molecule counts so your first
molecule gene one there's four copies
for reads of it that basically these are
condensed back into just one molecule so
even though you have twelve reads of
gene one the duplication and replication
is removed collapsing these back into
three individual copies and you do the
same for gene two and you have six reads
but there are only two molecules
identified due to the UM eyes so once
you remove any redundancy you retain the
3 to 2 ratio of gene 1 - gene -
ultimately quantification based on um
eyes reflects quantities of original RNA
molecules
looking at the principles of Umi your
assumption is that if you take aren't
examples and perform or full delusions
and amplify each the same ultimately you
would have a fourfold difference in
reads okay so this is real data here
that on the left if you just look at
mapped raw reads and you go down your
dilution of RNAs from 20 nanograms to 5
milligrams to 1.25 nanograms the counts
are basically all the same so even
though you have a decreasing amount of
RNA when you just map the raw reads
because you basically multiplex the
samples together all at the same
molecular amount you are then resulting
in just the same number of rates per
sample however if you look at the map to
UM eyes and remove all of the read
redundancy whether you're looking at
brain universal human RNA RNA 1 or
universal RNA 2 you can see that when
you remove all the replicates you can
see you're decreasing number of
molecules so from 20-minute grams of
five nanograms you see this fourfold
decrease and from five milligrams to
1.25 nanograms you again see your
fourfold decrease so the Assumption here
is correct that when you're using
fourfold Aleutians with the same extent
of amplification you do see your four
for full difference in reads because
you've accounted for any redundancy and
are only looking at the molecules
here we have the work flow of the chi
seat targeted RNA library construction
it's a very nice quick workflow can be
accomplished in less than half a day
basically you start with your total RNA
perform cDNA synthesis and then perform
a primer extension and you Amaya
assignment to your genes of interest
following a beat cleanup you perform a
first stage PCR using a second gene
specific primer and in your third step
you perform a second stage PCR which is
basically your universal amplification
of your library including your sample
indexing ultimately one final be cleanup
and you have your library that's
prepared for sequencing
now when you're working with ultra low
amounts of RNA the kind of CQ px is a
kit that is very useful for this both
for targeted RNA as well as whole
transcriptome these are three prime
technologies that are ideal for single
cell and cell palate experiments one
cell up to a hundred or a thousand cells
as well as for ultra low inputs of
purified RNA from ten Peter Graham sub
one nanogram or 10 nanograms and
basically you have 96 and 384-well
options where you're coding each of your
cDNAs with a unique identifier and
these are again for both targeted and
whole transcriptome analyses
so the principle behind this is that in
each well of the plate there's an anchor
all ago DT primer that has both a unique
molecular identifier or you might as
well as a cell ID and there are 96 or
384 unique unique designs
so after reverse transcription all wells
from the plates are combined into one
tube so basically you synthesize cDNA
and take your entire 96-well plate and
put all of the cDNA and 1/2 but you can
do this because each cDNA has its own
unique cell ID afterwards each tube
basically gets one of the traditional
sample indices giving you the ability to
multiplex thousands and thousands of
samples together also you can go quite
the opposite
from a thousand samples to even only
eight transcriptomes but the nice part
about this is that you are basically
after performing cDNA synthesis you've
collapsed all of your transcriptomes
into one library prep how this works
visually then is on the left here you
perform individual Aarti reactions in
each well and just for brevity we have
two wells shown here and each well
receives its own unique cell ID this is
shown at the end of the anchored oligo
DT primer so after a cDNA synthesis you
pull all wells from one plate into one
tube here we have just our two cell IDs
represented and then perform all
remaining reactions and library preps on
one tube on the right here we have how
you can basically expand this to as many
plates as you want and each plate
receives its own traditional sample
index for subsequent sequencing
you look at your options basically what
type of RNA seek is the best so if
you're performing stranded RNA seek this
gives you your full complement of your
entire structure of your RNA both your
exons and your introns this requires a
hefty rebug ative 25 to 50 million reads
so if you're performing targeted RNA
sequencing from 100 to 1000 genes and
you're only specifically interested in a
specific region you only need about
500,000 to 4 million reads per sample
depending on your size of your gene
panel if you're only interested then in
3 prime RNA seek so more gene expression
counting you need only 1 to 5 million
reads or half a million to 2 million
reads so ultimately gene expression data
can be obtained from each method and it
comes down to a decision of sample
mountry budget as well as the scope of
the experiment when choosing what type
of RNA seek
so now shifting gears here to micro RNA
some current challenges facing micron AC
are that kits require up to one
microgram of input and are not ideal
with low RNA employee and often you
receive poor data quality with on target
micro RNA reads accounting for only
twenty to thirty percent of your total
reads and a high prevalence of adapter
dimers in addition many kits still rely
on gel band excision and this in
addition to being very tedious is not
precise in this segues nicely into the
final point that micro RNA sequencing
workflows are very tedious and because
the gel based workflows take multiple
days to get to sequencing
then responsibly developed a chi seek
micron aid kit and this is a micro nee
focused NGS prep kit and bioinformatics
what you can do with the kit is
differential expression analysis as well
as novel micro RNA discovery some
features of the kit are that it is gel
free and very rapid you can do a full
workflow in about seven hours and
there's no gel obsession or subsequent
extraction and purification it
accommodates a broad range of are any
input from 1 to 500 nanograms and
there's no adapter dimers at any RNA
input the library prep is also tuned for
prep from serum plasma bio fluid cells
and tissues here we have the workflow
you like 8 adapters to the 3 prime end
and 5 prime ends of your RNA you then
perform reverse transcription with
unique molecular index or um I
assignment and this is also where we
eliminate the adapter dimer from the
library following a cDNA clean up you
perform a library implication we now
have up to 96 sample IDs that can be
used during library preparation
and if you look at the type of results
that you can achieve with this kit
this is a typical file analyzer plot
from normal plasma so this is without
any gel extraction or anything this is
just what the standard workflow you see
a nice tight single specific peak
so in addition to having a very quick
workflow it's also my crowning
specificity that outpaces the
competition so with three tips here ty
seek versus two suppliers we performed
library prep on 100 nanograms Fork I
seek one microgram for supplier one
because that's the recommended amount
and 100 nanograms for supplier two
because that's the minimal amount and as
you can see on the page gel you see a
nice tight specific micro RNA band or a
tie seek but you see quite a number of
bands for supplier one and two in
addition you see a an adapter dimer peak
that is about equal intensity with the
micro RNA peak and as a result of this
you have to perform gel excision on your
micro RNA band from supplier one and two
so then when you perform subsequent
sequencing so we did this band excision
for supplier 1 and you see about 350
targets that are positively identified
but with Chaya CQC more than 600 targets
so even though we started with tenfold
less material so 100 nanograms you still
see almost double a number of microRNAs
with coyote
okay so now with library prep cupboard
let's move in to sequencing so here we
have some read length recommendations
for stranded RNA targeted RNA and micro
RNA for stranded RNA seek the basic
protocols have paired in two by 75 and
you can perform a paired in to by 150
when you're working with identifying
novel transcript splice site isoforms
etc for targeted RNA NGS a single and
one by 150 is required for high seek and
other kits may differ for micro RNA NGS
highest secret wires a single and one by
75 if you're wanting to sequence a
unique molecular IDs other kits do use a
1 by 150 and if you don't want to use
the um eyes of the cosmic Mike RNA you
can use a 1 by 50 and it's a general tip
I always recommend checking weather kits
require custom sequencing or custom
indexing primers
for read allocation for poly a selection
experiments for stranded RNA we
recommend twenty to twenty five million
reads per sample and for ribosomal
depleted samples we recommend about
fifty million reads per sample targeted
RNA NGS with kiya seek we recommend only
two thousand reads for targeted gene up
to fifteen thousand reads for targeted
gene depending whether you're doing
shallow moderate or high sequencing for
micro nee NGS a general catch-all
recommendation is five to eight million
reads per sample for difficult FFP and
fluid samples we recommend ten to twenty
million and if you're working with fresh
frozen cells and tissues we recommend
less than five million reads for sample
tip one the kits with um eyes can help
you optimize your read allocation by
revealing the amount of read replication
so for example if a targeted RNA NGS and
you're doing a high number of reads but
you're seeing tons of read replication
you can back off your read allocation
that being said tip two it's always
better to over sequence you can always
work your data down but the last thing
we want to do is not seek one deep
enough and find yourself having two
brief sequence tip three the number of
samples that you can multiplex depends
both on your application your seat and
your sequencer as well as your reagent
cartridge
in here we have some basic
recommendations to load for the Chi C
kits and as a general note upfront the
optimal library amount may need to be
empirically determined but for kaisi
stranded nine PM ol peter moeller for my
seat 1.6 for neck seat and both for KY c
targeted on a NGS and micro no NGS and
pica molar for my seat as well as 1.2
for the next seat and is another tip all
sequencers are slightly different so no
to my sikhs are the same no to next
week's are the same so find your sweet
spot and arrow on the side of caution
so now let's discuss analysis so for
primary mapping and secondary analysis
for stranded RNA seek we recommend CLC
bio medical genomics workbench so this
is for both the analysis and
visualization of data from all major
NGOs platforms
targeted RNA NGS we also recommend CLC
but for KY seek targeted you also have a
gene globe data analysis Center and for
my chrony NGS we recommend CLC and fork
I seek micro RNA we also recommend
either the gene globe data analysis
Center or CLC gene globe is a very
stripped down basic analysis it's free
and basically gives you your primary
mapping and you can also perform
differential expression analysis COC has
much more advanced features that you can
modify and tailor your analysis
specifically for what you want
- looking at the CLC there is new ready
to use workflows and tools specifically
for the chi seat micro RNA and basically
it's workflows and tools that walk you
completely through both primary mapping
and differential expression analysis
specifically for micro RNA you can map
to mirror based version 22 and you can
select your species for mapping and the
tool ultimately supports annotation of
multiple species in order of priority so
if you say for example one to map a
human sample but to all of near base you
can move all of your available species
here on the left into the selected right
and map to all of Mir base
then for the CLC output there's multiple
sample reports in a top-20 expressed my
grenade species so in the top here
reports for many samples can be combined
to get a complete overview of the
analysis as samples 1 through X and you
can look at the top 20 mature sequences
in this example also in the bottom here
you can look at the top 20 abundant
species for both mature and proceed
sequences and these can be displayed in
a summary table across the analysis
furthermore CLC can feed into ingenuity
pathway analysis and combine your
results with curated biological
knowledge so to discuss this further
this is where tertiary analysis comes
into play in the term in the form of
ingenuity pathway analysis and IPA
basically asks what's next by modeling
analyzing and understanding complex
omics data she can analyze your gene
expression your microarray data your
snip data and delve into a deeper
understanding of metabolomic proteomics
and RNA seek data and what it does is it
basically takes your data and integrates
it with highly curated databases of
everything that's been published so not
only does it allow you to assess your
data it allows you to assess your data
in the greater context of everything
that's already been known so it allows
you insight into where to maybe push
your experiment and also what's unknown
with your data so it's an invaluable
resource and can save you quite a bit of
time so instead of digging through
manually through the literature
everything's already curated and it
connects your data specifically to the
public knowledge database
in addition another avenue here for both
secondary and basically from primary
analysis through tertiary analysis is
ohmic soft erase studio and with this
you can take your RNA seek fescue files
and sample meta data and upload it into
omec soft
and what this does then is that it
integrates your expression data with
omec soft lands expression data and
funnels this all into ingenuity pathway
analysis
what do we mean here basically Amex off
lands is a method to store and explore
its data and think of it as a central
hub to gather public disease-related
data in the land content can be
organized by disease focus and is a
repository for thousands of omec samples
so basically on the left here you have
thousands and thousands of data sets and
this is integrated then with your
particular data set and on the right you
have curated findings that are published
in literature and other the other
databases that feed into ingenuity
pathway analysis and when omics oft
interacts with ingenuity pathway
analysis you basically are left with a
biological analysis of each data set as
well as a comparison of your analysis to
all mix oft analyses more details here
on a rail and so I've already mentioned
a little bit of this but it allows you
to store manage search and visualize
your data and you can analyze millions
of genomic samples across multiple
platforms there's omec soft hosted data
content for uncle and diseased land
genetics land etc and you can also have
privately built customer lands
all right so let's finish up here with a
look at our genomic services so why
should you look for Kai agenda for
genomic services basically it provides
you the flexibility and expertise to
execute your experiment so you can
either just turn to Kai Xin for sample
prep only or you can have a complete
sample to insight to workflow so you
have extensive expertise here
and you have unique access to both RNA
and manufacturing from collagen and
access to Cotton's innovative
technologies as well as consultation and
guidance from lab scientists and the
service core labs are located in either
hilde in germany and/or Frederick
Maryland so when you look at the
workflow the kaijin genomic services
quality is at its acute at its core so
you have consultation and experimental
design then you have sample submission
where QC is done on the samples you then
have library preparation where again QC
is performed ultimately next-generation
sequencing is performed and complete
that that data analysis is performed as
well so ultimately when the data is done
it is delivered to you as a customer and
you also have one final consultation as
well as follow up with the experiments
and the Kaizen service corps has a broad
array of poor product portfolio
extensive offerings both in sample prep
as well as NGS and qpcr and ultimately
for data analysis and interpretation so
anything that we have shown here today
including the bioinformatics can be done
by the cod and genomics Service Corps
one more slide on the RNA services are
that you can perform RNA isolation from
FFPE laser capture microdissection and F
NAB samples as well as mRNA seek and
micro and seek whole transcript MC as
well as targeted RNA seek
and also what else can the cottage in
service score do for you you can work
through translational insights from
Discovery to world real world evidence
so you can start with customized content
and then work through the Kaizen service
corps for isolation and ultimately all
of your secondary analysis and tertiary
analysis to arrive at even developing
early phase biomarkers
ultimately in summary what we've worked
through today is that NGS success
depends on your sample source your
specific sample types so cells tissues
FFP and bio fluids and often these two
are mixed both your sample source and
sample type but just because you're
getting bio fluids from a specific
vendor or so doesn't mean that the
quality is the best so as always I
recommend doing a check on ensuring that
your sample source at the bottom here is
well controlled and well understood
because quality is at the base and
everything is built on the quality of
your initial samples so once you have
your samples you have your extracted RNA
in my recommendation is to choose a kit
that gives you flexibility but to
analyze as many analytes as possible for
your library kit one thing that we
always recommend customers is that when
you're doing bead based clean ups to
remove all traces of an ethanol ethanol
that continues over through library prep
and leads with adapter dimers and
spurious artifacts for sequencing pay
attention to the details make sure that
your read budget is correct that your
sequencing parameters are right and that
you are loading an appropriate amount of
library on your sequencer ultimately at
the pinnacle of the pyramid is that you
the primary secondary and tertiary
analysis is of paramount importance
with that we'll end for today I'd like
to thank you for attending the webinar
and feel free to write any additional
questions that you have in addition feel
free to write now my email Jonathan
Schafer at Chi Cheng comm thanks
everyone